deswegen also am sagt uns jetzt bitte
nicht ja ihr müsst damit leben sondern
ich dachte man lieber ihr müsst damit
leben dass wir ganz normale menschen
sind ich sags mal so hallo ich meine
lieben freunde und herzlich willkommen
zu einer etwas anderen umkommen pvp show
sage ich mal
wir möchten heute ein wenig über die aif
quatschen bzw allgemein pvp pve pvp
sachen und zwar ist es für uns nicht
mehr möglich dass wir irgendwie pvp
sachen aufnehmen können weil einerseits
zb bei problemen wird funktionieren die
kompletten server hier einfach nicht bei
cyber games ist es so dass man egal wo
man herrn oft egal in welcher sekunde
man wird immer eine ersten minute schon
per hand einfach nur geschlagen und
direkt getötet oder auch was bei mir
gerade der fall werde versucht so drei
vier runden oder so aufzunehmen ich wo
drei hintereinander mit der hand getötet
dann wird sie getötet und dann wurde ich
in der vierten runde wo es eigentlich
ganz gut lief war ich mit vier leuten da
alle hatten keine rüstung ich hatte
rüstung und ein typ geht einfach nur auf
mich darauf die komplette zeit noch mich
läuft einfach durch alle durch ignoriert
die schläge und ja ich weiss nicht simon
pro woche lang gehen rechts das ist ein
recht hast du das ist eigentlich
verliert deswegen möchte ich an meiner
stelle nun ganz gut sagen das ist von
mir definitiv kein pvp mehr geben wird
wenn sich das nicht irgendwie ändert
weil mich das echt schon der beamte ist
wenn er leute einfach meinen ja ich
brauch aufmerksamkeit ich unbedingt die
aufnahme stellt sich die ganze zeit vor
mich wenn ich eine begrüßung machen will
schlagen direkt auf einen mann zu valve
game spielt bei hugo braun ist es noch
ganz in ordnung aber ich weiß nicht also
ich finde das alles nicht so toll
deswegen konnten wir heute dann keinen
computer bringen weil es einfach das
problem waren es knapp wird springt ihr
schon wieder einfach nur um und schlägt
die ganze zeit nicht ein das macht mir
zwar keinen schaden anrichten ist
trotzdem voll auf dieser schwarz guck
dir diesen schwarzen typen normalen
meisters er hat mich wohl auch schon
getötet na gut kommt man doch noch sagen
ja also möchte ich ein bisschen kaputt
aber ich wollte was sagen also wie kann
ich schon sagt also
also die eine hälfte der leute die mir
schenken uns mit tausend sachen und die
andere hälfte der leute ernst tour
entlang
ich habe dort neben überhaupt bewusst
schaden will da wären die richtung das
ist unser ziel
folgen wir die eine hälfte der leute die
spiele beschenken uns in die andere
hälfte leute die klubs tod das problem
ist man weiß auch nie jetzt genau wird
er als etwas schenken wenn es frieden
will dass es töten das heißt manchmal
töten wir leute die uns beschenken
wollen dass wir die arschlöcher
manchmal lassen uns von leuten tüten die
uns nicht beschenken wollen weil wir
dachten wir uns schenken und dann ja im
endeffekt kann man weiß nie weiter als
etwas gutes zur als böses und die leute
können auch mal superstar nie was gut so
was blödes man kann auch so tun als
welches sein freund schenker ist
natürlich durch sozusagen und deswegen
also ihr helft uns nicht damit wenn wir
uns sachen geschenkt oder wenn wir uns
direkt von anfang an mit der faust po
box und die ganze verfolgt ihr helft uns
am meisten wenn ihr videos von uns sehen
wollt damit ich weiß also kein spaß und
witz ich weiß dass du kein spaß es gibt
unter euch die folie auf versauen wollen
wenn's dann gibt's mal wieder leute die
einfach nur ins video wollen aber
ernähren sie sich vor einstellen oder
auch was bei mir zu weit bekämpft war
ich gucke mich so um wand ist er dann
immer so unserem kreis steht rechts
neben mir so ein typ der gerade mit
diesem komischen effekten auf mich drauf
schlagen einfach nur eine aufgabe wollen
so kommt es jetzt wieder weil das video
dann kaputt und man kann ja nicht so
eine scheiße plan wo man das video zu
ändert so leute ihr müsst dann schon
wirklich in mir selber denken denkt ihr
wir laden ein video hoch wo ihr direkt
auf uns drauf boxt einfach nur damit
ihren der aufnahme seien ein witz und
der held in der aufnahme oder so so und
im endeffekt das ist die eine sache die
an der sache ist uns geschenkt wird auch
langweilige aufnahmen weil mir meine
sachen geschenkt bekommen dann ja dann
haben wir selber nicht die chance
irgendwie das spiel so zu spielen wie es
eigentlich vorgesehen ist deswegen leute
in so einer form wie es anläuft geht das
nicht mehr weg also vielleicht doch so
10.000 5000 abonnenten hatte
der controller als spielen und conti das
mal ganz kurz jetzt eben zeigen was im 1
schauen wir mal wie zum beispiel ihr
könnt alle mitspielen weil es gibt ja
diesen befehl wer ist eingespielter
westcon kräften us kräfte gibt ein
steter kommt auf display und premium
habe so
und jetzt 205 ok ja warte ich noch
darauf hin so ich weiß ob ihr ist ob ihr
es auch so kleine elektro ist gerade
gestartet habe immerhin will 2 ich weiß
jetzt auch so kennt als nicht premium
spieler so jetzt sind alles blau leute
drauf sobald ich darauf komme es an
abgestürzt bei mir wird steht gerade
landschaft wird also gedanken an das ist
halt alles seit wie half finde ich das
alles das ist zwar eigentlich eine super
idee dass diese ganzen sachen zusammen
bringen wollen
allerdings ist da dann wiederum die
sache dass für youtube das ist sehr
kompliziert weil da sind so viele
zuschauer einfach oder so viele user
zusammen auf einem haufen die ein
wirklich alle irgendwas personen können
beziehungsweise da in virum schreiben
können und ein nerven
es gibt ja auch vernünftige user und
euch das möchte ich ja gar nicht sagen
ich möchte nicht alles schlecht reden
aber so wie es zurzeit ist so kann das
nicht weitergehen das wird sich hierzu
angehört ihr folgendes problem aber für
uns auch wirklich ein problem auf ganz
abgebrochen was ich muss ja ganz neue
joint also spielgerät eingezäunt ist es
noch mal ganz kurz
erstmal wird ein steter runtergeladen
das heißt so viel wie ein
das problem ist wenn die spieler dann
freue mich immer zehn prozent das heißt
alle nicht prima männer werden gekickt
und der ganze zauber ist voller leute
die uns halt folgen uns trocken
so jetzt also wieder land unter jetzt
bin ich hier drin ich bin mittendrin ist
es spiel los so aber es hält nicht lange
so weit ist aber voll ist jetzt bewegung
alle und zugleich werden bestehen
bleiben dann wird der server creation
der sache ist doch einfach rote karte
kurz core i5 2 ok guckt jetzt bin ich in
einer lobby aber ich werde gleich wieder
jeden moment einfach gekippt oder alles
fängt an zu harken ja jetzt guckt jeder
bleibt stehen alles haken erreicht wenn
wir unter geklickt
deswegen können wir keine schrauben will
spielen
es geht nicht leute survival games
wollte ich gerne machen geht nicht wir
brauchen immer 1000 runden bis wir eine
vernünftige aufnahme haben wo wir mal
ein bisschen länger überleben weil
einfach zehn milliarden leute ein direkt
boxen oder 1 millionen sachen schenken
marino gewinnen kann es ja wieder
langweilig ist muss eine gesunde
mischung geben das eher normal spielt
als wären wir normale user dazu kommen
jetzt endlich wieder leute an hey holt
euch doch neue accounts und so was alles
ja aber es ist ja im account spiel also
ich hätte keinen spaß mit dem anderen
kommt spielen
das ist ein neuer account spieler drei
runden bisher weiß dass ich das bin dann
ist das spiel schon wieder sieht man
dann auch wieder im chat das sieht man
dem video sieht man heißt und dann ist
es auch wieder die sache warum sollten
wir uns neuen account kaufen es geht
jetzt nicht ums geld sondern es geht
einfach ums prinzip
das ist auch einfach so dass wir es auch
so hinkriegen können weil wir sind eine
große community und ich weiß dass wir
das eigentlich auch hinkriegen können
dass wir vernünftig miteinander umgehen
und dass auch leute die zum die zum
beispiel mal irgendetwas kritisches in
die kommentare zum beispiel schreiben
wir sind ein bisschen weit her gegriffen
aber kritik darf jeder äußern solange es
vernünftige kritik ist und wenn einer
der vernünftige kritik äußert vernünftig
behandelt wird dann ist das auch alles
gut aber ich habe letztes gelesen hey
luca ich bin den rahmen da gemacht das
ist ein bisschen zu groß er kommen 3000
dann hey bist du schwul der ist voll
geil und so etwas verstehe ich nämlich
auch nicht warum müsste dann immer so
reagieren versucht dann mal menschlich
miteinander umzugehen wir sind alle
menschen und ich glaube auf der straße
wenn wir uns das zu begegnen würden und
mit der meinung ankommen würde dann
würdet ihr es auch nicht so sagen
und genauso hier auch auf den servern
wir sind ganz normale youtuber wir haben
wir jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen
internet bekanntheitsgrads ein bisschen
pseudo berühmtheit sag ich mal man kann
jetzt eine richtige berühmtheit nennen
und kennen halt ein paar leute und
deswegen sind wir hier halt in minecraft
auf die halb in unserem fachgebiet bei
ok wird fachgebiet aus soul
anführungszeichen minecraft und hier
käme uns halt viele deswegen werden wir
von vielen verfolgt ich muss mich jetzt
einfach mal umdrehen und da sind wieder
ganz viele leute hinter mir wo ich
gerade am arsch der welt stehe aber es
ist einfach die sache dass ihr uns auch
einfach behandeln können die ganz
normale leute das einfachen nicht sofort
auf uns eingeschlagen und so was alles
ist einfach traurig und so können wir
auch das nicht weitermachen wir wollen
das natürlich gerne weiter machen
allerdings ist es so wie es zurzeit ist
nicht möglich sagt er wollte ganz
einfach
zweimal will können die spieleserver
gegner vor uns alle das heißt also
irgendwie können nicht für wirklich
richtig spielen also mehr klasse weniger
können wir das spiel spielen weil heute
das ist der grund warum krank und wer
ist es denn noch entfernen
captains park als diese ganzen
amerikaner da die machen das auch nicht
mehr weil es einfach nicht möglich ist
weil man von allen geboxt wird und so
weiter das ist captain sparkurs letztes
mal wieder hunger games aufgenommen dass
da auch total unmöglich auswahl direkt
auf ihn drauf gegangen sind obwohl es in
amerika noch ein bisschen gesitteter
zugeht und hier in deutschland ist es
einfach so hayden youtuber die müssen
wir direkt töten
ich weiß nicht also könnt ihr das nicht
akzeptieren also jetzt mal an die leute
die das vielleicht gerade sehen und so
was mit uns auch schon veranstaltet
haben also jetzt veranstaltet in dem
sinne von uns direkt getötet oder sachen
geschenkt könnt ihr das nicht
nachvollziehen wir sind ganz normale
menschen und ich glaube wenn dann
normaler user wer wie zum beispiel
gerade im chat panzer mariechen oder
sogar panzer mariechen gegen proxies tor
spielen würde ich auch proxys würde
panzer war enix geben wenn sie nicht
irgendwie ein richtig großer youtuber
wäre also das ist also die sache dass
wir bevorteilt werden
wer nur weil weder in die sondern sind
ja diese berühmtheit da genießen dürfen
das ist zwar einerseits cool dass ihr
uns schaut und dass ihr das cool findet
dass wir damit euch spielen das sieht
man auch immer jetzt auch daran dass
mich jetzt wieder welche verfolgen also
dass ihr wirklich auch ihre aktivitäten
sieht und das auch gut findet aber nicht
so bitter das ist genau so was wie mit
dem stalken oder so wenn man dann oder
hier bei dir im chat das ist einfach
unangebrachtes verhalten weil sie mann
wurde im livestream einfach draußen
seine adresse reingeschrieben die jeder
kennt und in seinem impressum danach
lesen kann und diese pace es ging nicht
darum dass diese person das gemacht hat
was er allgemein auch schon irgendwie
doof ist wenn man das macht das jetzt
auch nicht so cool aber einfach dieses
tausendmal spam und so dass es einfach
unangebrachtes verhalten und da wollten
jetzt einfach mal so ein kleinen schau
dort hier geben dass ihr da so ein
bisschen vielleicht ein bisschen an euch
arbeitet und dann können wir da
eventuell bald auch mal wieder trouble
in meinen will oder irgendwas auf
bewerber nur aufnehmen wenn sie aufhört
uns in zwei mal zu verfolgen
ja aber das wird nicht aufhören deswegen
wir wollen das noch mal sagen wenn ihr
wirklich aufnahmen wollen das volllaufen
am ball vorbei an macht das sind wir
folgt uns nichts server erfolgt wo nicht
hörten uns nicht direkt besser weil
beginn voll scheint einfach müssen diese
band spielt er gerne mit uns spielen
aber nur wenn wir uns normal behandeln
wie normale menschen wir wollen doch
einfach nur noch sein okay
es wird sagen haben eigentlich als das
ist unser problem und ich geh jetz auch
runter hier
ja das war es so wenn ihr der meinung
wenn ihr unsere meinung verstehen könnte
das einfache posiert oder und schreibe
einfach mal die kommentare wie ihr das
finden würde wenn ihr den ganztag
verfolgt werden angesteckt und jetzt
jetzt ich weiß noch mal ganz kurz meine
sache weil einige leute schreiben
kommentare ja ihr seid youtuber das ist
nun mal so damit müsst ihr leben blabla
ja natürlich wir müssen damit leben wir
leben ja auch damit aber die sache ist
die man kann es auch ändern und es nervt
einfach das ist genauso wie das zb
promis wie justin bieber oder so die
werden gestoppt von ihren fans die
hängen jetzt vor der tür
bei uns ist es so wenn wir auf servern
sind dann verfolgen uns die kompletten
fans und wollen uns töten oder irgendwie
sowas also das ist echt ein bisschen
doof
deswegen also am sagt uns jetzt bitte
nicht ja ihr müsst damit leben sondern
ich sag mal lieber ihr müsst damit leben
dass wir ganz normale menschen sind ich
sags mal so und das soll jetzt keine
beleidigung sein an euch oder so sondern
einfach nur ein aufruf daran dass wir
das eventuell schaffen könnten dass das
ganze ein bisschen gesitteter abläuft
bisschen mensch menschlicher ein
bisschen legitimer und ich hoffe ihr
versteht einfach was wir meinen
sie ist schlank geworden loriot damit
wir das heute noch nie hochladen können
dann bis zum nächsten mal anschaut
treasuries und konkreter und konnte